- So I just go back to
release the damn videotapes.
Tell me what did Pelosi know?
When did she know it?
Let's find out who are
these guys like Epps.
There's several of them.
Who broke the windows?
That's where you need to start.
But like going after people
who are just out there,
pissed off about the election,
I mean, let's not forget,
you still have people
who have not accepted
the election from 2016,
because they believe that Trump
and Putin and Russia
all stole this.
Why?
Because these liars,
like Pelosi and others,
told the American people that.
The media went along with it,
and they brainwashed people
all over this country.
So anyway, that's all
I have for January 6th.
- I yearn, I yearn for
those good old days,
those good old days of 2017,
when Hillary was
allowed to tweet
that Donald Trump is an
illegitimate president
and it would not get
taken down from Twitter,
when Stacy Abrams would say
she won the gubernatorial
race in Georgia,
and it would not get taken down.
You used to be able to
question these things.
(dynamic music)
I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me today
is a former US Congressman from
California's 22nd district,
and now the CEO of Truth Social.
Devin Nunes, welcome
to the Ruben Report.
- Dave, it's my honor.
Great to be with you.
- I am glad to have you on.
We met for about 10
seconds in passing
at Mar-a-Lago a couple weeks ago
during the "2000 Mules" debut.
And you're sort of
right in the thick
of the political and the
social media firestorm.
So let's start, actually.
Well, you know what,
let's start somewhere else
because of that background
that you got behind you.
I sense you're in Florida,
but you're a former Cali guy.
What's going on here?
- Yeah, we looked
around, much like you,
in terms of where to
put the headquarters,
and it quickly got narrowed down
to Florida and Texas, Tennessee.
And then this was a good spot,
relatively close to Mar-a-Lago,
just on the other side of
the state, easy to get to.
And then of course,
it's a free state.
It's a fun place to be.
We have a lot of people
who wanted to be here
in terms of our tech folks.
So it kind of made
perfect sense to be here,
which is odd because
you would think
a startup tech company
for the last 40 years
would've been in Silicon
Valley in California,
but that wasn't
even on our list.
It didn't even make the list
of even a potential place.
- Was there literally
not even a moment
where you guys were like, oh,
just in terms of the manpower
or to get the right
programmers or whatever else
that you were like, oh,
we have to do this
in Silicon Valley,
or the ship had
already fully sailed?
- Yeah, it didn't even pop up.
I mean, look, for one,
I know my background
for the last five years,
involved with the Russia hoax,
and the impeachment
hoaxes and all of that,
it's not even, sadly,
if you're more center right,
there's a lot of
places in this country
that are not safe to be.
And I can tell you, the
Bay Area is one of those.
- So as a Cali guy,
and someone that represented
California's 22nd district,
as I said, is this sort
of bittersweet for you
that you have to relocate,
and do Truth down in Florida,
the free state of Florida?
I mean, I left California
about six months ago.
I have not looked back.
Oh, by the way, I don't
know if you know this,
but every time I gratuitously
mention California
on the show, I put
money into this jar.
- Yeah, you have to.
I don't know who gets
the money, though?
That's what I wanna know.
- Well, originally,
I was gonna help
transport someone
from California, a sane person
from California to Florida,
but we've decided, I'm actually
gonna export a Democrat
from Florida and send them
to California, I think.
- Oh, that's okay.
That's a good idea.
I was gonna tell you, there's
plenty of homeless people
that you can pick up and
move from California to here.
- Yeah, exactly.
But was that bittersweet
for you in a way?
- Yeah, look, my family's
still out in California.
My family's been there, in some
cases, for almost 100 years.
My family came from the
Azore Islands and Portugal.
Ag family, and
pretty much everybody
is right around that area.
I was born there and
I represented there,
and I don't take pride in it.
I mean, I love the state,
but it's just untenable to
operate a business there.
I mean, especially one that's
owned by President Trump.
It wouldn't even be possible.
So where I am in the
middle of the state,
we like to say that we're kind
of that last place that's left
that's in a little
bit of sanity.
I know all the people
in LA and San Francisco
call it drive-through country,
but it also happens
to be the bread basket
of the solar system.
Everything grows there,
from almonds to
grapes, to raisins,
to every damn thing you can eat,
they all grow there and
it's a beautiful place,
but as you know, I
fought my whole career
to try to get water
into the region.
And because the kind of the
green global warming gods
that that they pay homage
to there in California,
I mean, we're actually cutting
the damn state off of water.
So look, at some point
I'm doing this job
to open the internet back up
and give the American
people their voice back,
and I'm proud to do it.
And we can probably
get into a lot
about how I kind of
stumbled into this,
but look, it bothers me
what's going on in California,
and look, I wanna see it
fixed, but for the time being,
I just don't know how you do it.
It's one of the
reasons why I went to,
I think the way you do it
is you have to win
the hearts and minds.
And right now, people are
just getting so dumbed down,
they're getting so destroyed.
It's just tough because they're
cut off of information flow.
- Okay, so obviously
we'll spend most
of what we're talking
about here on the tech side
and how we can save free
speech and all those things.
But as long as we're
talking about California,
and I always put
money in the jar,
let's continue a little bit.
Gavin Newsom just
won the primary.
He's obviously gonna
win reelection.
Is there anything to point to
that is hopeful in California?
Or do you think that it just
needs to hit that rock bottom,
whatever it might be, if
it's not there already
before things turn around?
- Well, I keep thinking
it's gonna hit rock bottom,
and I've been thinking that
for the better part of a decade,
but I think what's
happening instead
is that we're losing so
many people like yourself.
So people are essentially voting
with their feet,
they're leaving,
So it's making it
harder and harder.
So we've got major, you wanna
talk about "2000 Mules,"
I mean, "2000 Mules"
is legal in California.
And so how they've
really destroyed it
is they essentially,
now it's mandatory voting,
mandatory registration.
So if you go to the
DMV for anything,
you get registered to vote.
And in fact, I think
it's totally chaotic.
We don't know who the
hell's registered there.
Some people get
multiple ballots,
and they made legal what was
done in the last election
in other states,
which is, thank God,
right now, still illegal,
but they made it legal
to essentially go harvest
ballots in California.
So I think a combination
of basically the whole
state awash in ballots,
the Democratic Party
awash with money
so that they can afford
to pay as many people
as they need to go
pick up ballots.
It's made it very hard.
You can only kind of
go to those places
that are almost like the Alamo.
You have to actually have money.
If you get targeted, like
I have been several times
for the last few
election cycles,
we had to actually
go raise money
from all over the nation
so we could fight back.
And I think that's
gonna be the one place,
you say, is there any hope?
Look, there's 52
congressional districts there.
They gerrymandered
the hell out of it
with this commission
this last time.
But I actually think
that it is possible
that we could pick
up two or three
or four congressional
seats in California.
And look, that has not been
possible for the last 10 years.
So that's probably the
only bright side right now.
Obviously, you had the crazy DA
that got beat in San Francisco.
There may be a recall from
the one in Los Angeles.
But look, I'll just tell you,
I was in Sarasota
for a couple weeks,
and kind of the first time
that we got the
headquarters going,
and then went back
to California,
had not been back
for a couple weeks.
And I was greeted at
the little donut shop
that I go to get a cup of
coffee by a homeless guy,
like standing in front
there, with his bike,
essentially not letting you
in until you give him money.
The owner of the business
can't do anything.
I mean, you know this
'cause you just left there.
But I just don't know.
I think people get a little bit,
it's almost like
Stockholm Syndrome,
and people have just
become accustomed to it.
What started, probably, I
remember five or six years ago,
there was a church in my home
city, Tulare-Visalia area,
65,000 people in Tulare.
And there's a church that
said, oh, well, we're a church.
We're gonna help people.
Good thing. They
wanna help people.
Well, there was a couple
homeless people living there.
Well, pretty soon it went
from two to 10 to 24,
to when the church
said, whoa, whoa, whoa,
we can't have this in
our church parking lot.
Well, now there's just
homeless scattered out
through the whole city.
I mean, there's hundreds and
hundreds, just in my home city.
And that doesn't include the
district that I represented.
There was homeless
everywhere there.
And of course, you
know what it is in LA.
But I think that's just
spending all this time
in California and Washington
DC, the last decade or so,
when you come to a
state like Florida,
you realize like,
whoa, wait a second.
I just had a flashback
to what it was like
to grow up in California
in the 80s and 90s.
I mean, that's what
it feels like here.
It's safe, it's clean, and
it's totally different.
So I think it it's gonna
have to hit rock bottom.
I think more people
are gonna have to leave
until people pull their
heads out of their ass
and actually start to
start to vote right.
And part of that is the
free flow of information,
which is why I left Congress
to start Truth Social with
former President Trump.
- I know this is not
gonna surprise you at all,
but I have three employees in
this room with me right now
who all moved with
me from California
to the free state of Florida.
One of them got a
California ballot
to vote in this past election
to his new address in Florida.
I mean, that tells you
everything you need to know
about what's going
on over there.
- Yeah, and I've heard
that time and time again.
I don't even know.
I mean, this is how
sophisticated they are.
They learn people move out,
and they're still
sending them ballots.
And I guarantee you, I'm
sure if you're a Democrat,
and you moved out
or a independent,
I guarantee you get the ballot.
I'm not so sure if you're a
Republican, you get the ballot.
- He is a Republican.
- He got it? Okay,
wow, that's good.
(Dave laughs)
Their tech guy, he probably
didn't show up to work
because of COVID or something.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Made a mistake.
Didn't take him off the rolls.
- All right, so before we
dive into the tech stuff
and sort of what shifted you
in your career and all that,
I have spent literally
zero cumulative minutes
talking about January
6th on my program.
To me, it is a
complete distraction.
It is impeachment number three.
It is gonna end with
nothing going anywhere.
It's going to make a set
of very confused people
about the principles of
America even more confused,
but because you've been in
this with Trump for a while,
because you've been trying
to fight disinformation
because you were involved
around the impeachment trial
and all of those things,
is there anything
you'd like to just say
about it broadly,
or specifically,
because I just feel that I
have no need to entertain this.
That's really just
how I feel about it.
- Yeah, well, I think you're
right to not entertain it.
I think kind of my
quick thoughts are this.
The institution in Congress,
and all the institutions in
Washington are collapsing.
So kind of what we just
talked about with California,
it's happening in our
nation's capital, also.
And what I say is we've
just entered a dark chapter
of American history right now
that started in that
2015-16 timeframe,
with that first piece being
that people within
the FBI and DOJ
thought it was perfectly okay
to get involved in politics
and frame a
presidential candidate,
and ultimately, the
entire Republican Party.
So it started with,
oh, it's a dirty trick.
Get the FBI to
participate in it,
get informants to participate,
walk all this stuff into the FBI
and the DOJ in
different locations,
Like what came out in the
recent Sussmann trial,
fully engage the fake
news media with it,
but at the time they just
justified it in their own mind.
"Well, it's just Donald Trump.
So nobody cares about that.
Let's just write crap about him
and crap about him
and crap about him."
And first it started as,
well, let's just call him,
that he has ties to
Russian oligarchs,
and then suddenly
they moved that,
'cause there were no ties
to Russian oligarchs,,
and say, well, what the hell?
Let's just say he
has ties to Putin
because they knew that
Hillary Clinton's emails,
they were afraid.
By the way, they never
actually came out, the emails,
that the Congress had an
actual investigation going on
because she destroyed a
server, an illegal server,
taking you back
to that timeframe.
So from there it just got worse.
I was the one who
essentially came out,
like essentially on day one,
or probably second
or third week,
And I said, Russia stuff,
what the hell are you
guys talking about?
Like, I was just, like
six months prior to this,
you, Obama, and your whole crew
wouldn't do a damn
thing about Putin
as he invaded Crimea, he
was involved in Libya.
He was involved in Syria,
and we won't get into foreign
policy discussion here today,
but I knew it was pure, utter,
I think I can say
bullshit on your show.
- [Dave] You can say it.
- So I knew it was total
bullshit because I knew,
as the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee,
I knew what they weren't doing.
So you can't come out
right after the election.
We were told, hey,
nothing unusual.
Yeah, Putin's a
thug, he's a bad guy.
He messes around.
I mean, it's not unusual for him
to mess around in elections,
but all they really found
at the end of the day
that Putin did was he
bought a few Facebook ads,
which by the way, weren't
even in the states
that mattered, right?
So that was the extent
of actual hard evidence
that we had on the
Intelligence Committee.
We didn't have anything else.
And that was the position
of the officials in the FBI
and the other intelligence
agencies that we worked with,
until they decided to
turn on the operation.
So they ran a dirty trick
all through the campaign.
And then they just doubled-down
with the full power
of the FBI and DOJ
and you know the rest.
And I had to take
the brunt of that.
We exposed it all.
Then it led to Mueller,
the Mueller investigation.
Total corruption
They couldn't find
anything on Russia,
but they found plenty
of process crimes
that they went after people on.
I had to sit out there
every single day.
You know how hard it is when
you've got 95% of the media
that is listening to
Democrats in Congress
and people, former intel people,
current intel people,
retired four star generals
who would constantly
come out and say, well,
"I can't tell you what I
know, but it's really bad."
(Dave laughs)
And I had to sit there and
say, "No, you guys are lying."
And you're totally full of it.
So I had to sit there
and withstand that
so that Mueller hoax, and
then it goes into impeachment
the whole Ukraine impeachment
was a whole nother debacle
and then look, there was a riot
that occurred at the Capitol.
And so what do we need
to talk about there?
It's the same thing that
I said after day one,
which was, look, there was
intel that we knew about
that now you're starting to
see some of that come out.
Pelosi knew about it.
The Democrats knew about it.
That's why the Trump
administration was willing
to have National Guard
ready for the Capitol.
That's not unusual.
It happens when you have
big protests, especially,
or when you're getting ready
to have an inauguration.
It was the first time
that I'd ever seen.
I mean, they put up the
fences for anything.
I was there for two decades.
I mean, oh my God,
there's gonna be a protest
at Supreme Court, boom.
They do like a double fence.
If you've been to
Washington, DC,
the Supreme Court's
essentially right across
from the Capitol.
They'll put like
double fences up.
Get plenty of security.
That's just for a
Supreme Court protest
for a few hundred people.
So the fact that they
had the intelligence,
they had approval for
the National Guard.
There was no fencing put up.
And now the way that they're
going about all this,
when you got this guy,
so it really appears
like Russia hoax 3.0.
It's just like
another version of it.
You've got this guy, Ray Epps,
who clearly was inciting people.
The guy is not even
being arrested.
He's not even being interviewed.
I mean, nobody just seems
to know anything about him.
The dude's living
out in Arizona.
That's just one example
of what appears like
there was some type
of federal involvement
in instigating the riot.
And when I say the riot,
it should not be hard.
There's some 14,000
hours of videotape
that I have called for
when I was in Congress,
and even today, like release it.
They won't even show the
Republicans the videotape.
So they're selectively
showing tape.
There's cameras all
over the Capitol, Dave,
just so you know, but
there's plenty of video.
We never even got
the exact number
of how many people
went into the Capitol.
But what I've said from day
one is release the videotape
and the people that I
want busted and prosecuted
are the ones who
were fully masked up.
They somehow had exactly
the location to go to,
and exactly the tools they
needed to break windows.
And to this day, I'm not
sure, I could be wrong.
It changes every day,
but I'm not sure they
have located those,
what appear to be maybe two
to three dozen people
at different doors
that broke those windows.
Those people should
be prosecuted
to the full extent of the law.
We still don't even know
who the hell they are.
- I sense though, what
you're saying subtly
is that they might
be feds, right?
- I don't know who
the hell they are.
We don't know.
I know the Epps guy, I
mean, that's clearly fishy.
He's living out in
Arizona somewhere,
and hell, the night before,
he's on video tape with people,
Trump supporters that were
out there for the rally.
Which by the way, the
idea that President Trump
or anyone else
would hold a rally
on our nation's Mall
in Washington, DC,
that's only out of the
norm when Trump does it.
I mean, there are rallies there.
I was just there
this past weekend.
They had the Pride rally,
and they had some gun rally.
I think last time I
was in Washington, DC,
they had like a police officers,
for fallen police
officers rally.
So the idea that it's
like unusual somehow
that people can have rallies.
That's at the cornerstone of
our democratic republic here.
And if you go back just four
or five, six months before,
you had BLM riots who
destroyed the Capitol,
shut it down, and I damn
near got attacked coming out,
when Trump gave his
nomination speech
in Washington, DC,
just months before.
So the idea that suddenly now,
oh, you can't have a
rally, that's nonsense.
So I just go back to
what crimes were broken?
Well, clearly the people
who broke the windows.
The rest of the people, a
lot of the people had no clue
that they couldn't
go into the Capitol.
'Cause look, the Capitol is
normally open for the public,
except when, like during COVID,
when Pelosi has closed it down.
So I just go back to release
the damn video tapes.
Tell me what did Pelosi
know, when did she know it?
Let's find out who are
these guys like Epps?
There's several of them.
Who broke the windows?
That's where you need to start.
But like going after people
who were just out there,
pissed off about the election.
I mean, let's not forget,
you still have people
who have not accepted
the election from 2016
because they believe
that Trump and Putin
and Russia all stole this.
Why?
Because these liars,
like Pelosi and others,
told the American people that,
the media went along with it,
and they brainwashed people
all over this country.
So anyway, that's all
I have for January 6th.
- I yearn, I yearn for
those good old days,
those good old days of 2017,
when Hillary was
allowed to tweet
that Donald Trump is an
illegitimate president
and it would not get
taken down from Twitter,
when Stacy Abrams would say
she won the gubernatorial
race in Georgia,
and it would not get taken down.
You used to be able to
question these things.
But that's actually
a perfect segue
to what I really wanna
talk to you about,
which is big tech censorship.
So you are running Truth Social.
It's obviously President
Trump's platform.
I think some people know
that the infrastructure
is run by the Rumble Cloud.
For total transparency,
I am part owner of Rumble
because of the deal
that we did with Locals,
and I think we're building
some awesome stuff.
So at some level, we are
kind of in business together,
although this is the first
time that we've ever spoke,
except for that quick hello
we had a couple weeks ago.
So was it a very natural
transition for you
to say, okay, here
I am in the swamp.
It's corrupt as hell.
Everyone's lying
about everything.
Maybe I can help clean things
up on the private side,
which would be the
social media side.
- Yeah, it's a pretty
interesting story, actually.
So I wrote this
little pamphlet book
called "Countdown to
Socialism" in July of 2020.
And so remember, this
is before the censoring
of the Hunter Biden laptop.
And of course, all these people,
millions of Americans
getting booted off
or censored on the
tech tyrant platforms.
Well, I had actually
already quit Twitter
because I realized that
I was being shadow banned
and it was totally
useless for me
to even be on the platform.
So I was the first member
of Congress to go to Parlor.
So Parlor was the company
that ultimately got,
Bezos cut off their servers,
and essentially
killed the company.
But I quickly realized
that I had at Parlor,
I mean, finally,
so think about it.
I was on Twitter from
essentially the very beginning.
I had, I don't know, a million
followers or something,
maybe a little over
a million followers.
Well, when Parlor
got shut down, Dave,
I had 4.2 million
followers on Parlor.
And Parlor, that was like in
a year, in one year's time.
So I knew the censorship
that was going on.
I'd also been
capped on Instagram.
I've been like at
100,000 people.
I liked Instagram, actually.
I like to use it, I
think it's interesting.
People all over the
globe are on it,
and we'll get more
to Instagram later,
'cause I think it's important
in terms of business aspect
of what we have to do.
But Instagram, I've been capped
at like 100,000 followers
for like three years now.
I don't grow and
I used to use it.
So anyway, 2020,
I write this pamphlet,
warn everybody about
that this is happening.
At the same time, I notice
when, oh, Dan Bongino,
who you know, who was
also there that night.
So I had my little
podcast that I was doing,
essentially, and the
reason I created a podcast
different than you, it wasn't
to make money or anything.
It was actually, I
had to get a way,
find a way that my constituents
and people all over the country
could hear directly from
me without being censored.
So I used my national
email list and database
and all of everything that I
had through my campaign side,
and I was able to network,
created this little podcast,
and Bongino calls me.
He's like, man, "You're really
doing well on this podcast."
It was crazy.
I'd probably never beat you,
but like I would be in
the top 20 sometimes
when I first started it.
And anyway, he tells me, "Hey
man, you gotta go to YouTube."
I'm like, oh, okay.
Shit, I didn't know
anything about YouTube.
I had heard of it,
I knew about it.
I have like a little
account there,
but I'd never really
thought about doing video.
So we started doing a simulcast.
So I'd put it on the audio side,
and then I'd also
put it up on YouTube.
And what happened
was incredible.
My audio just kept going
up, up, up, up, up.
My video, like shot
up immediately,
and then if it could
have had negative views,
it would've had negative views.
Like it flatlined.
And I said, this is impossible.
This can't be possible.
So I told my team, I said,
let's find a fricking
video player.
There's no way I'm sending
this out to a million people.
Like I have enough
family members
that would at least
feel sorry for me,
(Dave laughs)
and at least click on it
to gimme a view, you know?
And of course, it
didn't make sense either
'cause the audio
listens were going up.
It's in the heart of
the election time.
I mean, it's all
about Russia hoax,
Ukraine hoax,
impeachment hoaxes.
All that stuff is hot.
People wanna hear about it.
And I had really good
guests on the show.
We came across
this Rumble player,
and it's a great story because,
so I had 9,000
followers on YouTube.
I thought, oh, must be okay.
I don't know how many
people are on YouTube.
It sounds okay to me.
Didn't know any better.
So I call up Rumble,
and Chris from Rumble, the
owner, the CEO of Rumble,
he said at first he thought
he was under investigation
by the Congress.
(Dave laughs)
And then he quickly went into,
'cause I just asked
him a question.
I was like, look, man,
I just wanna place
I can park my video,
and if I put in
"Devin Nunes Podcast."
That was the name of it.
Not very creative,
but that was it.
And I said, "Will it come up?"
And Chris was like,
"Well, yeah, of course."
Like that seems kind of dumb.
I said, "Well, go try it
right now on YouTube."
And that was like
a moment for Chris.
It was like, oh my God,
you couldn't find it.
Like he couldn't
find the podcast.
Like he didn't
believe it existed.
And I had to send him the link
so he could eventually
find that, yeah,
there was a channel
and there was a link.
So long story short,
I get up on Rumble.
And so like I said,
9,000 followers on YouTube.
In three weeks, so no
one knows of Rumble
in the United States of America.
No one, this is
like pre-Bongino,
pre anybody who
had went to Rumble.
I had 35,000 followers
in three weeks,
and in three months,
I had almost 400,000.
And now, I'm sitting
here today at a million.
Now I'm just kind of
posting news clips on it.
But that shows you right there.
I mean, those are
real numbers, right?
I gave you the Parlor numbers.
I gave you the Rumble numbers.
And in the book that I wrote,
I essentially warned people
about that there was a funnel
effect that was taking place.
It wasn't so much that
95% of the news media
is fake and slanted, 'cause
I can handle the 95/5,
because I think we have
a lot of good places,
between the podcasters
like yourself,
and all the different
news companies,
the investigative
reporters that we have.
We can hold our own, 95 to five.
But the difference between
10 years ago and today,
and I learned this
through the Russia hoax,
and how people's
perceptions were
and what people were learning
is I realized that we
were just 60% of America
was just kind of tuned out,
never even knew anything
about the Russia hoax.
And what I call it
is the funnel effect.
So it's when you take that 95%,
you feed it through a funnel,
which ultimately becomes
these phones right here
that are going through
YouTube, Facebook,
Instagram, TikTok, et cetera,
and then the left is deciding
what people are able to see,
especially those people
that are most important.
Like conservatives,
people that always vote,
they're gonna know
the difference.
But it's those people, they
only vote in general elections.
They don't pay attention
a whole hell of a lot,
but they'd wanna do
their civic duty.
And I mean, we sat there for
year after year pounding away.
It was clear the only people
that had anything to do
with Putin in Russia,
were Hillary Clinton
and the Democrats,
and Adam Schiff and
Democrats on the committee.
I mean, it was plain
day, direct evidence.
In fact, this
wasn't complicated.
But yet nobody knew it.
And you still had,
even by election 2020,
you still had over half
of Americans thought
that the Republicans and Trump
had something to do with Russia.
It was just a big problem.
And I knew that
until that funnel,
that funnel that
the left controls,
which is why they're
so ticked off
about Elon Musk buying Twitter.
Until you get rid
of that funnel,
we're gonna continue
to have this problem,
like the problems we
discussed in California,
and the problems we
see in Washington, DC.
That's kind of the
short story of it all.
- It's so interesting
because the problems
that you were trying
to solve for yourself
are exactly what led
you to this new career,
and that's exactly
why I started Locals.
I was having the same
exact problems as you.
You'll love this one.
I remember, this is a
couple years ago now,
when I was about to hit a
million subscribers on YouTube.
And at the time,
you may remember,
you could go on Social Blade,
where they did a live
track of subscribers.
So you could literally
just watch a graph
and the numbers would grow.
And every time I got within
about 20,000 of a million,
I would lose 50,000, and then
it would slowly grow again.
And then I'd lose 40,000.
And it took me months when it
should have been way before.
And then what did
Social Blade do?
Well, YouTube
deactivated their API
so they could no longer
track in real time
because it was
becoming too obvious.
So one of the things that I say
all the time about social media,
it's not the stuff that
we know that they're doing
I'm worried about, it's the
stuff that we do not know
that I'm most worried about.
So, okay.
So all of that added up.
How is Truth going to
solve some of the problems?
We could go into all
of the shadow banning.
You don't see subscriber videos,
the bans, the
censorship, okay, fine.
We can do all that.
My audience gets it.
How is Truth gonna solve
some of this stuff?
- Yeah, so look, one of
the things that we're doing
is we're riding on top of,
we call it riding on
the Rumble rails, right?
So the same thing
that Locals is using,
Rumble is getting
into that marketplace.
It's critically important
because we have to
have data centers
that these big giant
tech companies can't
kill and cut off.
So that's why we've
partnered with Rumble,
and then what we're doing,
the product that we're
building out right now
is one that we envision
is taking kind of the best
of all of these social media
companies that are out there,
in terms of, Twitter's kind of
just a simple message board,
then you have a lot
better technology
at Instagram,
Facebook, and TikTok.
So we're trying to take
the best of all of that
and put it into one platform,
and people who have
seen Truth Social,
which we're only just a
few months old right now.
And right now, we just have
a simple chronological feed.
No, we don't use any algorithms,
but you will see already
that we are trying
to do a really good
job with video,
and no surprise,
we're using Rumble
for our video infrastructure.
So we're trying to tie
all of this together
so that we have a product
that takes the best
of all these social
media companies,
because, and I said that
we would come back to this,
and here we are, the
eyeballs in this country
are on Instagram and
at TikTok, right?
You essentially have kind
of an older demographic
that are on Facebook that are
probably over the age of 50.
From 50 down to 25, Instagram
just dominates the market.
And then under 25,
which just is really scary as
hell, Chinese-owned TikTok,
and all these young
people on TikTok.
For us to compete with Twitter,
like, look, we're
not gonna ban people.
That's kind of an
easy market for us.
Like people that
wanna be on Twitter,
get news, that sort of thing,
'cause Twitter sucks so bad.
And a lot of our people are
never gonna go back to Twitter.
So that's kind of
an easy market.
But to really grow this company,
we've gotta get into
the mainstream of people
that don't wanna just do
politics and news all the time,
but wanna communicate and
actually social network,
knowing that we're not
gonna shove some algorithm
in their face, I think that's
our comparative advantage,
is we're gonna do a lot
of things really well,
but you're not
gonna be canceled.
We're not gonna steal your data.
We're not gonna shove some
algorithm into your phone
on the stuff that we
think you need to see.
And that's our
comparative advantage.
And it's really just about
filling out the feature set.
So we're in the Apple App Store.
We've been there for
a couple months now.
We just got truthsocial.com.
Now anybody can sign
up from any device,
including you can
sign up on Android,
but you just have to kind
of bookmark it and go back.
And then we're hopeful
to get into the Google
Play Store here soon,
so then it's simple for
people that like to have apps,
and then it's really
about the features
that we're gonna be rolling out.
- So the features,
people love features.
There'll be more
features for sure.
But how worried are
you about just some
of the way the
internet works now?
So for example, Truth
is in the App Store.
Twitter booted Trump,
and then there was this
concern that if Elon,
if he ends up getting Twitter,
and he puts Trump back on,
if Trump was to go back on,
even though Trump has
said he won't go back on,
he's all-in on Truth,
but the App Store could
then boot Twitter.
That this is multi-layered
at many different levels.
- Yeah, so you cut right to it.
The reason that we
went to Apple first,
I've had a long, my whole
career, I dealt with Apple.
They're less woke than others.
They do have Republicans
that work there.
I dealt with 'em
for a long time.
President Trump felt like
we could work with 'em,
and that's why we
chose Apple first,
'cause we had to.
If you're not on
the Apple App Store,
and you're not in the
Google Play Store,
it's just tough to
ultimately compete
against Instagram and TikTok.
So now the good thing
is that we're trying
to be a family
friendly place to be.
So we're not looking to
have any illegal activity.
We don't want like
porn on there,
and some vulgarity is okay,
but you can't get
crazy about it.
So we really wanna
be family friendly.
And that right now is, so far,
we've had a great working
relationship with Apple.
Google, we waited kind
of for that to be last.
I mean, 'cause now we're up
on the web, truthsocial.com.
Anybody can get onto it.
Even if Apple was
to get rid of us,
you could still
have your account.
And Google's just
more problematic.
We already talked about
some of those issues,
but we're working with them.
At this time, I
can't say anything
that they're trying to keep
us off the Google Play Store.
But look, once again,,
we have a little
bit of an advantage
that we're not
looking for violence
and illegal activity
on the platform.
We really wanna keep
that to a minimum.
I think that's gonna
make it really tough
for them to kick us
off their stores.
Plus they already know, look,
they're not stupid here, Dave.
Republicans are likely
gonna smash the left
in the elections.
You see big tech running ads
constantly all over the place
saying how great they are.
So I think they are
a little bit worried
about what Republicans
could ultimately do.
So look, I think
here at Truth Social,
we're a family friendly place.
We're just not gonna
censor people for politics.
You can talk about
any damn thing
you want on the
platform politically,
but we don't want a
lot of the garbage
that I think they would
try to use to wedge,
to get us kicked
off these platforms,
and that's to our advantage.
- So when Elon, now it's
about two months ago,
first started grumbling
about maybe buying Twitter,
how were you feeling about it?
And how did you feel
when President Trump...
Well, I don't remember
which order it was.
Did President Trump first
say he wasn't gonna do it,
and then sort of went
after Elon a little bit,
or was it the other way around,
and what do you make of him
just getting in the mix?
- Yeah, I don't
make much of the...
I mean, I've only met
Elon Musk a couple times,
but he seems like he's real,
obviously brilliant guy.
Very, very sharp, but kind
of very funny guy, right?
It's why he has a big
following on social media
because he's a creative
dude, but if you remember,
and the fake news has
basically ignored this,
surprise, surprise, but
the mission of our company,
Truth Social, is very simple.
Like we're here to open
the internet back up
and give people
their voices back.
It's a very simple
business plan and mission.
And so I like to say
that President Trump
didn't need a new business,
and I sure as hell
didn't need a new job.
It's just that, what the
hell do you expect us to do
when you kick all these
people off of social media?
Including the former
president of United States,
who had no voice at all,
plus millions of his
followers had no voice at all,
not to mention all the censoring
that we already discussed.
So the fake news
has ignored this,
but when it came out originally
that the Elon Musk was
looking at buying Twitter,
we're like, hey, go for it.
Like that's our mission.
Like if you can bust up one
of those big tech companies,
great, have at it.
And so we've always
been supportive of it.
But at the same time,
what I said from
the very beginning,
I said, look, the place
needs a lot of work
because there's a hell
of a lot of bots there.
And we already knew that.
I knew that from my experience
on having a Parlor account,
a Rumble account, having
a big Twitter account,
And then also just in our beta
test period on Truth Social,
how is that possible that people
who had been on Twitter forever,
and Instagram, in many cases,
most people were
getting more engagement
on our platform
during beta testing
than they were getting on
these big tech platforms.
Now you can say some of
that's shadow banning,
some of that's censoring,
but I think it's
also that Twitter,
and you notice I've spent
a lot of time talking
about Facebook,
Instagram, and TikTok.
There's a reason.
Twitter is just
a global PR wire.
It's where when Barack Obama
wants to make a statement,
like he did last week.
He hadn't been on
Twitter forever.
And I dunno, he
made some statement,
I think, about the
shooting in Texas.
I mean, it's a place
for celebrities
and political hacks and
reporters to go put stuff out.
It's not where people
go to social network.
So from my perspective,
we're all for opening
this thing back up.
It's a global platform,
meaning Twitter.
I don't know if
Elon's gonna do it,
but I think what
he's realized now
is what we knew going back
is that it's full of bots,
and bot is a kind of a big term,
but it's basically, it's
a combination of bots,
spam accounts, fake
accounts, corporate accounts.
Every corporation in the
world has an account,
but the fact is they're
just not active,
and they don't engage.
We're very supportive of it.
And I think what you saw,
just to kind of
finish up with that,
is that I think Elon
made some funny remark
about President Trump, and
President Trump went back
and made a funny
remark about him,
and now President
Trump's basically,
it's kind of funny,
like why wouldn't he?
I get so many calls,
even from like, well,
I don't really
talk to fake news,
but from even people
who are not fake news,
and they'll say like, well, if
he runs for president again,
isn't he gonna have
to go back on Twitter?
I'm like, no, like why?
There's nobody there.
You could make a
different argument
about some of these
bigger platforms.
He would never go to TikTok
because of the Chi Comms,
but I mean, look,
Instagram and Facebook
still have a lot of people.
- Right, so what do
you think he would do?
I mean, I guess that's
the question. (laughs)
- Look, I think the
goal here is that,
from our perspective is,
just in the last 10 days or so,
we rolled out some
really important features
on our platform.
We've got some
additional features
that will hopefully
roll out here
in the next two to three weeks.
And then, I'd like to get
our platform to a point
where it does really take the
best of all those platforms.
And then look, we're gonna be
in direct competition to them.
And remember, we're
only open right now.
You gotta remember, we're only
open in the United States.
That's the only place
we're open right now.
So imagine, think about when
we open this up globally.
- Yeah, how concerned are you
that maybe Apple will be okay,
and Google will let you in,
but just the other trickery.
I mean, I know they can't pull
a Parlor on you, obviously,
because Truth is using
the Rumble infrastructure,
so in essence, it's
Truth's infrastructure,
but just some of
the other trickery
and shenanigans
that they can do.
- Well, you know what?
We've really built this thing
from the ground
up, piece by piece.
And that's what I kept saying
when I took over the company.
The fake news didn't like this,
but they said, "Oh, when
are you gonna launch?"
And I said, "Well, for sure,
it'll be after the
first quarter."
And of course, they
never reported on this,
even though I said it 500 times,
and I'll say it for the
501st time, is I said, look,
we're not on anybody's
timeline but our own.
Like we're gonna launch
when we're ready to launch.
So we wanted do it.
That's why we had to
we had to make sure
the Rumble Cloud was ready.
When we switched over
to the Rumble Cloud,
that's when we essentially
went out of beta
and opened up for
anybody on Apple.
Now we're up, now we have
our web-based application,
so anybody can get
it from any device.
But we're building this
block by block, Dave,
and we're doing it in such a way
that nobody's gonna be
able to shut us down.
I think what you
might be alluding to,
that we do have to
be sensitive to,
are DDoS attacks, attacks
to try to take us down.
And I know Rumble's
had some of that.
We've had some of that.
We know that's gonna be a
problem into the future.
But look, we have a
good team of people,
and Rumble's been
around a while,
and they're very, very helpful,
plus the team that we've
built here at Truth Social,
I think, outside of
kind of those attacks,
there's nobody that's gonna
be able to shut us down.
- Well, I love the fact
that you were in government,
you saw a problem.
You're in the private sector
trying to solve that problem.
That this idea that I
had about four years ago
is now part of the
solution to that problem.
So I appreciate you
taking the time, Devin.
- Oh man, yeah, it's great.
And I've been
flirting with Locals.
I've been on there.
Kind of watch it.
It's an interesting platform.
It really is a place
for those independent
content creators
where they're not gonna
have to be beholden
to kind of the big monopolies
or the big companies.
So congratulations,
and I think that-
- We built it for you.
Whatever you do
with it is on you.
It's as simple as that,
it's as simple as that.
- Yeah, no, I think it's
gonna continue to grow,
and I think it's gonna be
a great home for creators.
And we're gonna look to where
we can work with you guys,
continue to work with
Rumble and Locals.
I don't know if you know,
but some of your
engineers and tech people
have been very, very
helpful in terms of
as we've been building
out our platform,
and we're very thankful
for that support
for you and your team
that have offered that.
- Awesome, well, I sense
you'll be in Sarasota
a lot more often, and
since I'm here in Miami,
I guess we're
gonna have to meet,
what would be right
in the middle,
something like Doral,
or something like that.
We'll find something.
- Yeah, Alligator Alley, right?
- Alligator, (laughs) exactly.
We'll meet in the middle
at Alligator Alley.
They got the panthers
and the gators there.
Devin Nunes, it's been
a pleasure, thank you.
- Thanks a lot, Dave,
- if you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full
episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.